when you to start goods look at them now
you know global superstars this is a
near the beginning what they look like
now during the great conditioner
shortage
so like some of them of listening jobs
the early publicity shots I mean it
really does not suggest that success is
in your future check this out like how
do baby
don't you know I am NOT just a sex
object a human person feelings
not be treated like this huorchi daytime
telly on in the back daytime Delia used
to be this
and the glasses in the house they
weren't at the beginning they do they
came along as time with our time yeah
you know when you become a professional
at that you need sort of yes the
accoutrements of you started going to
sunny places the whole committee no it
doesn't but once but the Sun but you
didn't wear sunglasses and then when you
found that we were like I love
sunglasses
do you ever take them off you know the
big I got earlier you know the one when
I put the reins on the back there okay
uh-oh
it's a good place to explain people it's
something terrible wrong with you yes is
it fatal love you might make a lot of
people happy
no III have glaucoma for that the last
20 years okay
come on say it didn't get a great all
today oh that's right with sunglasses
nobody seriously Graham
you know the thing about Kagome is you
know I per a perfect a 20/20 vision so I
would go to do these eye tests and
people said but you said I don't really
need one cuz I've got perfect I could
read the bottom line and they said oh
that's one of the signs of a ma you
wouldn't have it have you ever had sort
of strange visions and their esteem
coming into the room and you know rings
around lights I went oh yeah and they
said and it's not from anything yeah
exotic
there's no I just think they're cool I
think Bono looks cool in them thank you
do you add just big boxes and boxes and
boxes of sunglasses though people give
you them as I think you well I do have a
lot of them oh yes I have a lot cuz I
just thought maybe the other band
members would like to try sunglasses
these ones these loans would I need
would have gotten Larry like try those
on I think they looked a natural fit and
everything these are quite clever these
sunglasses they've got the tars on there
these are quite cool for the edge that
they like
and because your bond with the band
yeah I can see I wouldn't mind doing a
glass swap with with Bob for a second
thank you oh it's about time Justice I
hope you'd knit I thought you'd never
see your eyes for one particular
very thoughtful ever see one now you
have this information you're never going
to be able to get it oh yeah just come
sit this poor old blind fauna hook
follow-on to this day after giving him a
kicking on Christmas
and Jimmy would tell a joke it would
take Brando three seconds to catch on
could you just as a favor because I know
that you know you some stars like to
give unusual names could you call him or
her up he